this is a truly shocking and appalling
case and I welcome the statement today
for serving police officer
admitting to some of the most serious
and devastating crimes I joined the Home
Secretary in making giving Tribute to
The Bravery of the victims who have come
forward but we have to face up to the
further evidence that this case has
brought up of appalling failures in the
police vetting and misconduct processes
that are still not being addressed by
the government and are not being
addressed in this statement and I would
say to the Home Secretary that given the
scale of the problems not just in this
case but in previous cases as well her
statement is very weak and it shows a
serious lack of leadership on something
that is so grave and affects confidence
in policing as well as serious crimes
we've seen repeated failures to respond
or take seriously allegations of
violence against women by a serving
police officer by others serving police
officers allegations of domestic abuse
not taken seriously in the vetting
processes and in this case a failure to
suspend for example a failure to suspend
David Carrick when rape allegations were
made in July 2021 even though the Met
police knew there had been domestic
abuse allegations two years previously a
misconduct process that concluded there
was no case to answer despite the
repeated alarms being traced a full
vetting check not triggered and David
carrick's permission to carry firearms
restored and most shocking of all is
that this happened at the height of the
alarm about Wayne cousins and the murder
the deeply disturbing murder of Sarah
everard
and this undermines confidence for women
confidence for victims but also for
police officers who are working so hard
and especially for women police officers
who may themselves have reported
misogynistic abuse and for officers who
are doing excellent work every day to
tackle violence against women and girls
and know that confidence in that work is
being undermined now we support the
commission as the new met Commissioners
determination to take action but this is
not just about the met we have had
concerns about misogyny and culture
raised in Sussex and Hampshire and
Derbyshire and gwent in police Scotland
and other forces
and there has been a lack of leadership
from the government on police standards
for years after the truly appalling
murder of Sarah everard by a serving
police officer home office ministers
promised change the then Home Secretary
promised to set up processes that would
prevent this happening again
that has badly failed
there are still no legal requirements on
vetting forces can effectively do what
they want they don't even have to check
employment history and character
references and some don't they don't
even have to interview people beforehand
and when the inspector came up with
damning conclusions that hundreds if not
thousands of police officers who should
have failed betting including corrupt
and predatory officers who have
committed including officers who've
committed offenses on indecent exposure
and domestic abuse are still in the job
the policing Minister refused to even
make it a requirement for police forces
to follow the recommendations of the
inspectorate they just Shrugged and said
that it was a matter for police forces
to follow
there's been no response to make this
compulsory to follow vetting guidance no
requirement to make it compulsory to
follow the reforms and all we've got in
this statement is a continuation of
existing Angelini review
and a new review another one on
dismissals which I welcome because this
had there are concerns that the
dismissals process has become more
difficult and has become worse since
well-intended reforms were introduced
but have not worked as intended so I
welcome that review but it was announced
in October and it still hasn't started
and all the Home Secretary has done is
re-announce it today and some of the
things that police forces have been
doing to tackle misogyny or to increase
diversity to improve their response to
communities and to Crime the Home
Secretary has dismissed as woke even
though they are about tackling some of
the most serious crimes and it's about
you how seriously they tackle violence
against women and girls more broadly
where we know that the prosecution rate
the charge rate for rate has dropped to
a shameful 1.5 it has dropped by
two-thirds over the last seven years and
again home office ministers promised
that tackling violence against women and
girls would become part of the
compulsory strategic policing
requirement it has been reported that
that has not happened can she confirm
that nine months after ministers
announced it she has not made it a
requirement in the Strategic policing
review to prioritize violence against
women and girls
Mr Speaker after the murder of Sarah
everard by serving officer labor called
for change after the horrific murders of
Bieber Henry and Nicole smallman labor
called for leadership after the shameful
case of child cue labor called for
reform after the shocking Charing Cross
station report labor demanded action
after the Stephen Port inquiry labor
called for reform
and after the case is right across the
country of abuse or of misogyny labor
has demanded change conservative
ministers promised action would be taken
but they have failed to do so labor will
change the law labor will overhaul the
vettings misconduct and standard system
because it is time for change and we are
letting down police officers across the
country who do excellent work and who
are being let down by these failures in
the system and most of all women are
being let down it's too late for all the
warm words in the home secretary's
statement what is she actually going to
do to make sure that standards are
raised